i don't know about you but i can never
get enough of minimalist money-saving
tips tricks and hacks and with this
crazy inflation what a better time to
focus on improving your finances and
reducing expenses than now so today i
will share with you 12 money-saving tips
that i plan to use to save more money in
2023 but make sure you stick to the end
because i have saved the best one for
last so number one is before purchasing
anything after you ask do i need this
also ask this question can i diy this
for example i recently needed a planner
because i want to plan out my daughter's
homeschool calendar i browsed briefly
through the internet and then i realized
i have a lot of notebooks in the home
and so i got out my handy-dandy ruler
and a pen and
i made my own
if you ask this question before you go
to buy anything you may be surprised at
just how many things you can do much
cheaper if you just do it yourself
number two is prior to tossing or
replacing your clothing consider how you
can alter it to make it work for you so
for example i had a dress that i wasn't
too fond of the sleeves so i cut them
off and i made them a bit shorter i had
two high-waisted dress pants that i
realized i don't need two of them so i
cut one of them and made them into
shorts because i didn't have shorts at
that time by doing this i saved myself
from purchasing new items prior to
tossing an item consider how you can
mend it to make it work for you and if
you aren't able to do so then consider
possibly having someone do this for you
it tends to be much cheaper than
actually purchasing a brand new item and
number three is if you just thought to
yourself well i don't know how to sew
then this is for you learn new skills
such as cooking sewing and gardening
these skills can be huge money savers
because as i mentioned through sewing
your clothing instead of having to
replace it you can just mend that or
even gardening you can have fresh fruits
and vegetables or you can freeze things
such as what we do learning these new
skills doesn't have to be even
complicated at all because you have tons
of videos at your disposal on youtube
for example and it's totally free and in
the case of sewing the kit that i have
is very small it takes up very minimal
space but i have saved quite a few
stuffed animals with these so make it a
goal to learn one new skill per season
and then the next season you can focus
on another skill and then if things hit
the fan you have a skill where you could
make things to be able to sell to other
people to make more money and who
doesn't love more money right so for
example i can knit and i can make
scarves and things like that i don't
enjoy it but i know that i have that
skill and should i ever need to sell
these sorts of things i can do so number
four is huge and it is to replace your
social media scrolling with youtube
videos podcasts or audiobooks that are
relevant to better managing your
finances minimalism or just saving money
in general think about it you can either
spend your time scrolling through
instagram watching what the kardashians
are doing or what other people are
wearing and what they have and what they
own and think about the things you lack
the things that you need more of or you
can listen to content or watch content
that is motivating you to own less to
desire less to free you from that
shopping addiction that you may or may
not have and also at the same time
motivating you to save more money to
learn how to better manage your finances
swapping this out can be huge i know
that for me when i purchased dave
ramsey's book the total money makeover
it was a huge life changer for me and i
got so motivated that on my commutes i
would listen to podcasts about saving
money and i would watch youtube videos
on that topic and i learned so much that
i hadn't before and this is kind of what
led me into minimalism but it just i
think goes kind of hand in hand so be
really cautious about the kind of
content that you are consuming and make
sure that it's something that's going to
actually help you get towards your goal
and tip number five is to have a lazy
quick go-to meal we've all heard of meal
planning as part of saving money
sometimes life just doesn't work out
that way you have a hectic day and then
you come home and you just don't have
the time to be able to make a
well-rounded dinner for those days have
a quick meal that you can just whip up
in 10 minutes what we do is we have some
shiitake noodles which don't need to be
cooked they just come in a bag prepared
some frozen veggies that we just always
keep in stock in the freezer some eggs
and some coconut aminos which is
basically the soy free version of soy
sauce and ta-da we have a stir-fry in
under 10 minutes
just make sure that you always have the
ingredients at hand so that on those
occasions when you have a crazy hectic
day you can just whip this up really
quick number six is also food related
and it is intermittent fasting or if you
just don't want to do intermittent
fasting just don't snack throughout the
day this is actually not something that
i've really heard about in terms of
saving money but it's one of the effects
that i have noticed through intermittent
fasting throughout the years and i've
talked a lot about intermittent fasting
and especially through my videos on my
experience with the keto diet which i
can link down below every time you eat
you're spiking your insulin levels when
you reduce your insulin levels you can
decrease inflammation in the body it
means that i am eating healthier meals i
no longer binge eat and i'm not having
to cook or prepare buying all of these
things in my home matter of fact we
don't really keep things like cereals or
cookies or chips or any of those sorts
of snacks in our home the snacks that we
do have are for our kids really and my
husband but it tends to be things like
fruits and those sorts of things
reducing the amount of snacking or
trying out intermittent fasting can
really save you a lot of money in the
long run but it can be so good for your
health however make sure that it's okay
with your doctor or nutritionist before
you try anything like that because i'm
not a doctor i am not a nutritionist
this is just what has worked for me and
i have noticed that has saved me money
as well number seven is to have a wish
list and i don't mean the wish list
where you tell people i would love it if
you would give me this not that kind of
thing although you can totally do that
if you want to by this i mean having an
area where you can jot down the things
that you would like to buy but you don't
really need or don't really need them
right away so for example you can jot
things down on a notebook or have it on
your notes app on your phone because i
don't want to just go to the store and
buy whatever with the high dollar price
tag i want to maybe shop the sales or
find a used version so by doing this i'm
kind of also giving myself the time
where i don't have to just buy it right
now because of the fomo and then at the
same time you may decide that some of
those items you jotted on your list you
don't really want them anymore and
number eight is for those items that you
want to purchase online so before you
actually click the buy now button make
sure to give yourself at least 24 to 48
hours with that item in your cart i have
done this a lot where i'm thinking about
an item that i'm going to purchase and
i'll just have it sitting there in my
cart for a few days because i know that
way i'm not going to forget about it or
i'm not going to have to search through
all the items to remember what item i
specifically wanted but at the same time
it gives me the opportunity to really
think about it do i really need it and
if i forget about it that's a clue that
i really did not need that item number
nine is something that i'm still
currently working on and it is a capsule
wardrobe i've shared with you about my
crazy spending habits back in my early
20s in a previous video this is
something that i have been working on
over the past few years and it is just
reducing my amount of clothing to those
items that really make me feel my best
that really match well with one another
and this means that i have to kind of
find a personal style but at the same
time something that's simple that has
the ability to be worn in different
occasions but i love this as a money
saving tip because through just reducing
your wardrobe to those items that really
make you feel your best that you love to
wear every single day you're kind of in
a way helping yourself from having that
desire to have more because it's never
ending you always want that extra piece
that extra accessory or whatever that's
going to make me feel better or look
better you can really kind of escape
that and then when you do need to
purchase something it is because one of
those items has just been worn out and
you can no longer wear that item number
10 is to have low maintenance hairstyles
i have mentioned that i cut my own hair
but recently i had tried a balayage
style basically i dyed my hair kind of a
blondish color i don't know i was always
curious to see what i would look like
with lighter hair and i had no clue what
i was getting myself into i did not know
that there would be maintenance involved
and i just went to my stylist and said
we are not having that so i permanently
dyed my hair a little bit darker now for
you if you want to have your hair styled
by all means do it but maybe consider
styles that are lower in maintenance
this would be kind of a good in between
where you can kind of pamper yourself
and treat yourself which is good but at
the same time you're also taking into
consideration the expense that you're
going to have and the time that you're
going to spend getting to staying there
coming back from the salon over and over
and over again number 11 is to subscribe
or use the apps to the grocery stores
that you frequently shop at and i kind
of cringe because i know i normally
would say unsubscribe from everything
but i have been subscribed to two
different grocery stores that we shop
out routinely and they send me coupons
all the time i recently received a
coupon for 16 off a purchase of 160 on
groceries and with the prices of
groceries i was like yes thank you for
us this has worked really well because
sometimes you will have items on the app
that will give you different sales that
are not really visible in the store and
otherwise you wouldn't know and you
would just pay the higher price tag for
and number 12 if you struggle with
impulse shopping remove any stored cards
from any accounts log out and delete the
apps most of the online shopping that i
tend to do tends to come from amazon and
or target but initially when i was
really trying to get rid of my crazy
shopping habits what i did was i removed
all of the cards from the accounts i
deleted the apps on my phone and that
way it just kind of made another barrier
so that it forced me to really think
about the item that i was going to buy
instead of just immediately click
buy now because it can be so easy to
purchase on impulse when you just have
it so easily accessible so this kind of
creates like a barrier to help you with
those impulse purchases and as the bonus
the best money saving tip that i can
give to you is to think of money as time
because if you think about it every day
that you go to work you're working for
what for money and especially if you
have a job that you hate this can be
very motivating because the more you
think about it that item that you're
gonna buy that you really don't need how
many hours of your time do you have to
work to be able to get that thing and if
you hate your job this will very much
motivate you to save money but i'm sure
that there are certain things that you
would love to be able to do but your job
keeps you from doing those things that
you want to do maybe you have a project
that you want to start or you just want
to spend more time with your family
every time that you spend money on
something that you really don't need
you're having to work more in order to
get it but really what i would love for
you to take away from this is any
purchase that you're going to make
consider how much time does it take for
me to work to be able to get this item
and is it worth it so that is it those
are my 12
13 different ways that i plan to save
money in the new year in 2023 if you
have any money saving tips of your own
please share them in the comments down
below so that we can all learn from each
other i thank you so much for watching i
hope that you have found this video
helpful if so please give it a thumbs up
and subscribe so that you won't miss
when i post a new video i can't wait to
hear from you in the comments and i will
see you in the next one bye for now